your character gets stranded at sea when
I'm just a little busy making out with a
cat who was staying out with me I her
probably say my boyfriend but I feel
like after having been stuck at sea with
Sam for 41 days and having witnessed
what how we were able to support one
another
I would first save my boyfriend and then
I would say Sam okay you can run free
and I'll bug one of your friends now I
feel like I would I don't know
I think I'd maybe oh I think I think
we're on the catch just pooed I think
I'd maybe be a teacher I really like the
idea of shaping young minds and
inspiring them to be anything that they
want to be and encouraging growth
through education it's important to have
a good strong sense of identity and self
and to not take anything too seriously I
think throughout growing up in this
industry it's all too easy to give your
power away and to let others opinions
really affect you in in a deep way but
yeah I think it's important to
constantly try and understand who you
are outside of the labels in which
others either give you or you design for
yourself um maybe we could make like an
Adult Swim version of secret life the
American teenager I might consider that
I think that would be a funny and off I
do keep in touch with some of the cast
of secret life Megan Park and I who
played grace on the show are still
extremely close and I actually had a
dream a couple weeks ago about the whole
cast and that we all had this little
reunion dinner and so I think Megan I
told her about it and she reached out to
Francia and I reached out to a couple of
the other cast members and I think
hopefully we might do a cast cast in her
soon
team Ricky all the way I mean I just
feel like he came around he discovered
that he wasn't perhaps the most
supportive father in the beginning but
recognize his mistakes and I'm all about
forgiveness and I'd like to think that
if I were in Amy's shoes I would find
forgiveness in order to create a happy
little family for my child I feel like
I'd get along probably the best with
Tammy actually the character from the
good movie that I just did adrift simply
because we both have really adventurous
spirits and are very keen on exploring
the world I'd like to visit every single
onsen in Japan which is probably
completely unattainable and an insane
bucket list item but I'm a huge fan of
hot springs and the Japanese culture and
has something that I would like to
achieve one day before I die
[Music]
um I think that you know it's one thing
to sign a petition or to retweet
something it's another thing to actually
take definitive steps to create change
and when we think about change we think
that we have to do something on a really
big level in order to create a lot of
progress but often times change can be
very simple and and it doesn't have to
be huge gosh I would get in so much
trouble for talking a lot about it for
me personally I can't wait to see what
you know Meryl Streep continues to do
just working with hers so outstanding
and spectacular and something I never
thought that I'd have the opportunity to
do and she really is my gosh they're so
cute she really is um the most dynamic
actress and and raises the bar for every
single person in her presence to be a
better artist who honestly I'm all about
that like joy life at the moment just
frickin laugh a lot and find the joy in
every moment and I think you look the
most beautiful
I do love makeup and I love putting on
some red lips every now and then I've
been really into this brand at the
moment called pinch of color I think
it's a pinch of color option and they
make all of their products without any
water so all their lipsticks and their
concealers have no water in them which
is really sustainable and really good
for the earth
I mean Never Say Never you know I think
it's a long life to live and depending
on which way our our politics continue
to go maybe I'll feel there's a guy
hiding right behind me think we're
playing hide and seek found you I think
there's a lot of opportunity for change
and I don't know if I'll be a supporter
of others running for a long time to
come or if I'll be finding myself one
day but I would never all these little
guys are from Best Friends Animal
Society and they're doing such
incredible work to save the lives of
thousands of little kitties and puppies
and you can adopt one yourself I'm
probably gonna take one of these guys
home today you can go to best friend org
to adopt a puppy or a kitty I just think
it's wonderful to support people who are
doing good work for other creatures on
this planet so check them out